depuis aujourd'hui se trouve sur the
barber shop un jeu dans lequel on va
tailler des bars voilà finalement ce
qu'on rêve de faire depuis huit ans mais
on peut pas parce qu'on n'est pas viré
ces partis nouvelle partie bonjour nous
sommes ouverts on va raser ces termes la
barre le voir garder le ya sa place
j'aurais peur
j'aimerais vraiment peur d'essayer de
partout [ __ ] je rêverais de faire ça
je suis ça comme ça là et de voir des
poils aussi l'on tombé de mon visage je
suis un peu chelou dans ma vie en fait
office j'ai perdu cinq de leurs petits
que je lui ai fait une entaille de son
style et je te refais une entaille
bâtard comme les welsches dans le métro
c'est un tout et le chef des métros toi
je te fais pleins d'entrain à l'émoi 5 $
j'adore on va juste ou laisser le non
non non non non non non non voilà il
fallait faire cette blague on l'a fait
et voilà on oublie ou mais un disque
live et on passe à autre chose auquel on
a la tête de la tête du mec en bas à
droite fictivement là on voit un peu là
la taille de barbe qu'il veut j'arrive
pas parler aujourd'hui finish
allez on y va c'était parfait il me not
le mec vraiment ils me jugent on vient
de gagner 50 dollars en deux minutes
voilà certes le mec achète une bombe 2
bis fait ça chez lui l'économie pixels à
30 euros continuer à aller à des barbes
ont besoin d'équipement spécial à fillon
pour acheter des équipements où ils
achètent
ok on peut changer maintenant j'ai un
rasoir je peux le coupé le haut le
talent attendez on va lui laisser les
rouflaquettes les bonnes roues flafla
pour les intimes
là il est bien stylé aulas il peut
pêcher aux héros maintenant on va lui
faire un le tuyau plus sale que j'ai vu
attendez je vois ça des fois dans ma vie
c'est des gens qui ont juste voilà ils
oublient de se raser sur un centimètre
carré de leur vie accès ultra vol en 85
dollars le mec pour trois ans il avait
des rasoirs jetables intermarché meinau
non ils préfèrent payer 2 85 dollars
allez merci ce qu'elle voit la même
chose en fait il faut tout pareil on est
d'accord
baptisé 1 allez on y va cette fois on y
va cacher on perd pas de temps c c'est
comme ça déchire à aux attentes et ils
vont être compliqués il fait chier le
mec si tu me paies 80 dollars pour te
faire un rasage à blanc là tu va me
payer une petite fortune je te le dise
moi te faire ton petit bouc
voilà le bouquet présent non je les fais
un truc dégueu mais ne fait pas chez moi
je vous le dis on regarde t il un petit
bout classes et des gueuses qu'on leur
fait il a kiffé
à qom allez allez en le point rebelles
du ruf jeu tout comme membré steak mais
les points d'euros mais la voilà à la
poêle robert howe elle est belle a comme
à la vache à lait c'est nul on passe à
autre chose encore un blanc non mais
j'en ai marre quoi finish c'est mon stop
on l'a déjà fait ça on doit leur faire
c'est infernal à la fin on s'ennuie on
va même dans le nez avec la tondeuse
allégués me my money suivant est là il
veut quoi ce go j'en ai marre aux îles
et paula alors là enfin bon bouc mon
gars et je parle pas d'animal attendait
c'est carrément bien ce qu'ont bien fait
c'est beaucoup mieux que tout à l'heure
à kom al dente
je vais une barbe al dente débat à
rawdon amène à regarder ils n'ont rien
ces plans sur le côté razr ok ok ok
voilà c'est fini allez allez allez allez
on est tous français f
pourquoi f olala est ce parce qu'il veut
le mec quoi je dois toujours lui faire
la même chose ya un bug là mon gars
avoir été si je fais rien et ce qui me
fait quand même nom va me payer
il me paye le coût à avoir bouclé un
[ __ ] aux eaux une nouvelle barbe je
zappe à martin miller c'est pour toi
miller je parle de mac mac miller
monnaie sonnante et when you're strange
bancaire
à juste du bois sec doit plus tard on
m'a puni pour cette trop longue
alors là il veut un truc tellement style
et il est tellement dur à faire et avec
lui me fait chier cette mèche rebelle la
auprès de l'oreille alors là on lui a
fait alors là mon gars regardant badoit
attention c'est pile si vous voulez
c'est pile annoncé un peu long ok chauny
qui avait fait chier j'ai paniqué même g
et tournus kg pique-niqué ce work faut
tout raser la un an merde c'est pas rasé
c'est tondu j'adore ce jeu c'est
finalement là on est en train d'exercer
le travail qu'un mec exerce dans la
vraie vie et qu'on n'est pas payé oman a
été génial alors c'est trop le mot amusé
un finish
tu me dois moins 100 dollars mais qu'un
la cité du rhin ok 100 $ ou 1 grecque
bon attention attention lie à la grosse
moustache du patron à faire ça c'est
chef de la mafia a manqué à cette
moustache la soupe à la fois ring
la précision oulala avec alain bressy
quels hommes circoncis
non c'est faux on est bon on est bon de
penser que les circoncis lui peut-être
avec rage des liens sur les gens ses
concitoyens qu'elle est le fun vous êtes
ses conseillers vous arrêtez ça tout de
suite
oh là là on lui a fait un truc tellement
génial la rh est le salon l'a tellement
il est fier de nous un des baies comme
défibrillateur parce que mon coeur a
arrêté pattes quand j'ai vu tu m'as
donné que 75 $ pour la moustache du
patron de la mafia à la nuque et 10 le
directeur alors la manga en à la
moustache de talent et à faire un atom
il manque des instruments non pour
allonger là c'est pas assez long sur
trucs comme en allonge sa moustache en
ag mais un coup de rasoir
regardez je vais faire un vieux poêle
nul qui reprend comment j'ai fait ce
poêle nul là j'ai ramassé les bois le
cas sur les grains de beauté qui ressort
de la paume savez les poireaux on
appelle ça c'est très bien dégueu
celui-là savez c'est relié à rien voilà
bonjour aujourd'hui je fais même à blanc
raymond clottu fidèles à on peut tourner
on peut tourner un peu incliné à
tondeuse voilà j'apprends ça au bout de
vingt ans de carrière c'est bien bravo
lucas hochart watts rien ce qu'il
fallait faire mais il faut lui faire une
barbe mal rasée mais mais mais un peu
bien rasé quand même
ok on part sur le razer petites lamelles
on va faire un sur deux
c'est pause qui se passe et à regarder
on l'a fait parfaitement mal rasé bien
assez mal rasé à eau ou bien rasé tout
lisse et ce sur tout le visage à 360° la
tension va nous payer au moins 100 $ 50
$ mec je te comprends plus ce groupe
choko pas mal
et merde cette petite rouflaquettes elle
m'énerve je vais le planter mais
regardez la ruf la quête elle a été
entraînée par thor et superman sans
déconner voilà nous y sommes
allez allez allez [ __ ] mais batman va
entraîner la halle et non mais mec
incroyable mon gars c'est un jeu
n'arrive pas à virer son ami portel te
mais [ __ ] de merde au olari rouler
d'âge ou celui des poils de barbe de son
piteux
donnons la de freestyle nul oui mais
voilà jean sillières contre 7,2 sur the
barber shop un jeu sympa même si la
nappe moyennement l'air il est
maintenant il est cool mais crois moi tu
es aux arêtes valentin arrête je dois
plus sega n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude eh ben j'ai plus de
plaisir voilà à l'aide dans les années
soixante dix où 91 60
bref elle dans les années et à tailler
la barbe de ce mec sur une musique un
peu old school c'était cool mais savoir
garder ses taux très bientôt dans ce
projet cette vidéo je vous dis à bientôt
tu as tout le monde dise
[Musique]